good evening I want to bring you up to
date on some of the things the
government is doing to defeat the corona
virus epidemic in this country and
around the world and first of all let's
being no doubt this has been a a sad sad
day 563 more cases a record in a single
day our thoughts go out to the families
of the victims all their friends but
let's be no doubt that if we can follow
the program that were currently set upon
if we can comply with the measures that
we've embarked on together then I've
absolutely no doubt that we will begin
to start to push those numbers down and
I will turn the tide of the Crenna virus
as I say in the course of the next few
weeks and months now I want to bring you
up to speed on some of the things that
were doing above all to protect our NHS
and we've shipped just in the last
couple of weeks 397 million separate
pieces of personal protective equipment
to look after our amazing NHS staff and
the Army reservists and others are doing
a quite amazing job of shipping that
stuff around the country and we're also
massively increasing testing and I want
to say a special word about testing
because it is so important and I as I've
said for for weeks and weeks this is the
way through this is how we will unlock
the coronavirus puzzle this is how we
will defeat it in the end and what we
need to do is massively ramp up not just
tests so that you can know whether
you've had the disease in the past the
so called antibody test because that
will enable you to go to work in the
confidence that you can't be infected or
or infectious second our people need to
know whether they haven't got it rather
than isolating themselves at home for
their reason and that's very very
important above all for our NHS staff
and of course it's crucial the people
who do have the disease are a
- to be tested positive and to take the
necessary steps to isolate at home in in
the way that I am doing and many many
others are doing as well and I just want
to reassure you on that last point that
although I am sequestered here in number
10 Downing Street I am thanks to
miracles of modern technology that able
to be in constant touch with my
officials with everybody in the various
departments across the whole of
Whitehall who is coordinating the
response to coronavirus and I'm
absolutely confident that we will beat
it and we will beat it together and we
will do it by staying at home protecting
our NHS and saving lives thanks very
much